こんにちはモテる男肇社長です私生きてきて27年間延々にモテるというものを陳宮し
てきたわけなんですけども
モテるためには様々な帰結があるんですよ顔ももちろん性格もそうですただ
モテるために大きなきっかけになることがひとつあります
それは何か妻匂いなんですよ第0印象といってもいいほどですかを見なくてもその人と
すれ違うだけでいいんじゃいかしたりいい香りがするとモテるんですよ
enjoy がする人っても自然に自信
実はモテると思うんですよねそういうわけで今回ここ僕の家じゃありません
私の後輩の実家に簡単にあの漁師に許可を取ってれば侵入しているわけなんですけども
なんとがしてこの後輩の部屋を持てるヘアでしたい
竜後背地たいよもっともてさせたいそんなこのもてお得肇社長からの特殊誘いセントで
はい ax のボディスプレー2000本準備させていただきました
そんないるかって思うと思うだろう大丈夫だアックア使用金がないからたくさんあって
も変わることはない
これでもすターゲットが自信をなくした時とかもてなきゃいけない時音なるほど勝負の
日の時
いつでも無限に ax のスプレーを使うことができる最高だろう
そして今でたくさん準備者がこちらの2種類クリックと sweet です
クイックなんですけど
光厳ところちょっと使ってましてそのあっ注力一番好きな夢なんですよね
持ってさあモテる男といいますかこの似合う男になりたい強な匂いがしますよすぐに
とっていうのはめちゃくちゃいい匂いするんですよ
甘いいろんな工夫処理済みしたんですけども今回はこちらの2種類かなり多めに準備し
ました
私のおすすめですターゲットが大家に帰ってくる前に
ここにある2000本の ax あれのこの何もない部屋になるべく
おいてあげましょう視覚的にも絶対もうアクセしなきゃって思っちゃうんで間違いない
が持てる意識が高く並べて部屋にいるだけですごいでいきましょう
[音楽]
ブーブー s 4 p
相手は2箱分置き終わりました
この区間分だけで約3万6000分くらいです
あっはっは
[音楽]
きっさあもう頭がモーセが降りまし
よし
単体には完成しましたあっくるー
関西0
[音楽]
河野時間かけて来ました ax ルームご覧ください
もう床はもう扉の開くスペース以外は全部 ax です
こちらのただの全部 ax この前バックスた後の中 max 机の m 圧痛
ロフトへの階段マンツ肝心の扉もワックス関連出るのでも ax 勉強漬けも ax
ですというわけないあのものすごいことになっ
てしまいましたただこれで彼は一生アクセに困ることはありません n 自信を持ち
続けることができます
足の踏み場がないんですよこのような ax んでから何を思うのか
それどう行動するのかどう喜んでくれるのか多分そろそろターゲットが帰ってくると
思うんで帰ってきたら部屋の方が全部 ax になっているサプライズ
早速モニタリングしていきましょう
あいろいろ語らせてください ok です
あとは大変三島チャオまじましょうさあやってまいりましたて年選手の部屋でござい
ます中には大量の ax が既に設置されておりますこれからターゲット帰っていき
ますがどういう行動をとるのでしょうか
これでなくちゃげになるとなかなかないと思うのでこの蒸気を見てなんのことは発する
か
たまたこの ax 乙くださいいい音がしてくるんです
に対しどういうレッツオープンということで帰っていましたにフォル
なにこれ ax ですっ
何分ブース分ああああ驚きを隠せません
ax そのトレイ2月ました装苑フランスってくれるぞ
ちぇっパッチ尽くしていますで動けませんそうですごいです
だからこれになっています
どうしてもの部屋のチームが楽しくありません
岡山
カメラ見つけましたね中盤のスペースを見つけました
というコンピューターですねくさんですね
th
うん
進めません
saas をマウスに手を伸ばしたカメラ目線でしっかりとボディにかけてゆく今使っ
てるぞスイートですね
もうめっちゃ良い良いめっちゃいい匂いいただきました好きはいログは好きですこれ
ですね決めすぎない印象を与えることなく魅力的な自分らしさを演出できる
フルーティーフローラルなさりげない香りです
本部使いの欺瞞可でしたを使います
続いてこれクリックですねクリック使ってればすぐをドラム4の通りでございます
じゃあいい
スパイシーシトラスのさりげない香り外れるようにフレッシュなトップのとか古い t
で打っていいなラストノートへの変がスパイシー1さりげない香りで爽やかで開放感の
あるイメージをゲットできます
数手術ておりますねはいこれホント
なんかイケメンに立つような匂いがしますねぇ
戦後喜んでいるようで何よりですが週間に戻してゆく
運動する同社のうりぬんだを定めや糞手に取る
2本撮りましたクリックとスイートんよってランクス皆さんも使ってみてください
すっきりと洗練していく
ua
goo
そういうわけあなたのゲームなどでマーク時計したーー
いやーなんかすごいスはこれ結構かかるんです時間って相当かなったらですよね
いっしょなんか分からなかったにょ始めありがとう始めた頃サマーこれサマー先ほど
ん最初にもんねーあぁイイーッ
開いてあげたヴェレーナどうでしたかやすく無いの中でも中にフレッシュできました
ずれクリスできればいいですけどちょっと多かったですね
ゴールといっしょなんだかわかりませんでした本当に彼がクリックとスイートフォグ
めちゃくちゃオススメなんで家でも本当に気楽に年
言うようになってフレッシュでクリーンでぜひ皆さん使ってみてください
北南
最近筋トレしてるんで金とでした後汗かいた後とかに使ってリフレッシュしています
そしてあっ曲なんですけどもボディースプレーだけじゃなくてこちらボディへとと
ボディーミストなるんですよ
すっごく多くないこんな種類があるフェス今すごいすごい日本限定てで竹とか
えーっだけどボディーショップパティ皆さんこちらを使ってみてください
はいそしてですね私肇社長今 ax さんとキャンペーンをやっておりますので皆さん
是非応募してみてください
キャンペーンの応募方法や詳しい概要は概要欄にありますのでそちらから是非チェック
してみてください
とりわけたでねはい服使ってもてくださいわかりました
最高全部ちゃんと使えよ
あっハール blr